on va parler d'une affaire qui a
beaucoup fait réagir ce week-end
il ya un groupe d'une trentaine de
journalistes se faisant appeler la ligue
du lol je mets bien des guillemets c'est
comme ça qu'ils se font appeler qui est
accusé d'avoir harcelé sur les réseaux
sociaux plusieurs personnes en majorité
des femmes durant plusieurs années
c'est un sujet du 12 45 de m6 plusieurs
internautes accusent une dénommée ligue
du lol de cyber harcèlement
derrière ce nom une trentaine de
journalistes parisiens qui à la fin des
années 2000 se serait acharné sur
plusieurs jeunes confrères et appeler
leurs communautés à faire pression sur
eux alors une trentaine de journalistes
prix se liguent entre guillemets alors
ligue en soi disant du lol soi disant
pour rire mais pour harceler des
confrères des consoeurs et ce sur
plusieurs années emilie ce que pour vite
nous recontextualiser la chose ne
rappelle la genèse
voilà en fait en 2009 au tout début de
twitter en france il y avait quelques
journalistes qui étaient plus influent
que les autres qui avait pas mal de
followers enfin à la mesure de l'époque
il avait créé un groupe facebook ou en
fait ils discutaient en dialoguer entre
eux voilà pour dialoguer entre eux et
sur seconde facebook ils ont commencé à
parler d'autres utilisateurs de twitter
et certains utilisateurs de facebook
sont allés sur twitter pour harceler
certaines personnes pour à chaque fois
qu'elle quelqu'un posté quelque chose
ils balançaient des enfants c'est
ensuite le mans du cyber voilà on va lui
dire classique voilà ensuite ça y est
ils ont divulgué des identités par
exemple certains sont même allés jusqu'à
au travail de certaines des personnes
qui étaient harcelées et eu des
photomontages envoyés à des enfants
enfin vraiment c'est vraiment parti de
très loin à caractère sexuel ans
exactement en se faisant passer pour la
personne qu'ils harcelé donc certaines
personnes ont eu des envies suicidaires
parce que forcément quand pendant des
années vous avez des centaines et des
centaines et centaines de messages et de
d'action comme ça alors ses revenus au
grand jour là c'est vrai ça récemment
pour quelles raisons survenu au grand
jour parce qu en fait quelqu'un a
dénoncé un des journalistes qui à
l'époque harcelé et qui enfin qui aurait
harcelé parce qu'ils disent non et qui
aujourd'hui se présente comme étant un
féministe et ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que à l'époque qu'ils harcèlent et
notamment les femmes et notamment les
féministes et les homosexuels alors
plusieurs de ses journalistes ont été
mis à pied à titre conservatoire
notamment dans le magazine dans le
journal libération ça fait puisque le
directeur de la rédaction a décidé de de
voir un peu plus clair dans cette
affaire c'est eux aussi d'ailleurs
ont sorti un papier parallèlement à
faire donc il faut un peu le ménage chez
eux ce qui est plutôt louable qu'est ce
qu'on pense quand même deux ces
journalistes qui devrait être exemplaire
et qui visiblement ne montre pas
l'exemple
moi je vais vous dire alors où la
défiance des français envers les
journalistes atteint des niveaux records
franchement je parle au nom des
journalistes en ce sens serait vraiment
bien passé de ce genre de polémique
après moi je pense que ces personnes
représentent un petit peu la verrue de
twitter la verrue des réseaux sociaux
c'est à dire qu'il faut que ce soit un
cadre d'exemple que ces personnes soient
vraiment condamner que ces plaintes
judiciaires s'il ya des plaintes fassent
l'objet de condamnations sérieuse parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on parle de cyber
harcèlement
on a l'impression que ce sont des gamins
qui voit là agissent en toute impunité
derrière des profils anonymes en réalité
parfois ce sont des personnes bien
installé avec du pouvoir qui harcèlent
sur les réseaux sociaux et donc du coup
il faut que ça se soit condamné pour que
plus pour que ça cesse et pour que ça ne
donne pas 10 et d'idées à des gamins par
exemple qui sont au lycée ou au collège
dit mais qu'est ce que vous en pensez
justement sur la nature de ses
harceleurs parce que effectivement comme
le dit damien on imagine toujours et on
balaye d'un revers de main en disant non
mais ce sont des gamins qui s'amusent
là on se rend compte que ce sont des
adultes avec une profession avec pignon
sur rue
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est vrai
que ce qui nous donne des leçons
aujourd'hui de féminisme et qui derrière
en fait il ya quelques temps harcelé
soit des personnes homosexuelles soient
des femmes
je trouve que c'est un peu facile 10 ans
plus tard j'ai vu certains messages
passés dire oh je m'excuse je suis
désolé l'ex les excuses ne suffisent pas
je pense que comme des mecs faut qu'il
ya vraie sanction un exemple mais je
pense que c'est pas liée simplement
monde du journalisme
je pense que chaque corporation à ses
brebis galeuses on doit avoir la même
chose en médecine très certainement
probablement chez les avocats en aient
eu dans le monde des acteurs du cinéma
donc je pense que dans chaque profession
il y a une parole qui doit se libérer et
j'espère que ça aboutira à quelque chose
un des sanctions et 2 que ça ne se
reproduise plus donc on attend vraiment
de la suite de cette affaire en tout cas
au sein des différentes rédactions qui
sont touchés visiblement on est en train
de prendre la mesure de la faire et de
et d'essayer de voir un petit peu plus
clair dans cette histoire le hashtag ccq
d'honnêteté n'hésitez pas à nous dire
est ce que vous en pensez notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux puisque on dialogue
ensemble mais nous en toute transparence